[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
for today's video i'm going to be
discussing some news pertaining to the
fantastic beasts film franchise
late last year fans were hit with the
shocking news that johnny depp
who plays the role of gaelic grindelwald
in the fantastic beasts franchise
was being dropped by warner bros due to
pending domestic abuse allegations
the departure of depp who's been playing
the dark wizard antagonist for the first
two films
left a huge hole in the franchise and
for a period
left warner bros frantically searching
for his replacement
there were many names thrown into the
mix for his replacement
however one name came up more than any
other across the internet
maz mickelson though mickelson initially
announced that he had yet to be
contacted by warner bros
it didn't take long for them to cast him
in the role as shortly after the
dropping of depp
it was officially announced as the new
dark wizard maz has been in a ton of
films including rogue one
a star wars story hannibal casino royale
and many others
and i think that he'll be a valuable
asset to the fantastic beasts franchise
the third film is currently under
production at least in studios just
outside of london
and the film is expected to be released
in the summer of 2022
despite his willingness to accept the
role and take the torch from johnny
mickelson has been nothing but
respectful toward the former fantastic
beast star
and has publicly commented on the matter
job-wise
it's obviously super interesting and
nice nicholson said
it's also a shocker that it came after
what happened which is just super sad
i wish both of them the best these are
sad circumstances
i hope both of them will be back in the
saddle again really soon
additionally during a discussion about
mickelson's new film
another round the actor was asked how
his take on the villainous character
will differ from depths
well it's going to be me so that's the
difference mickelson quipped
then he got serious no this is the
tricky part
we're still working it out there has to
be a bridge between what johnny did and
what i'm going to do
and at the same time i also have to make
it my own
but also we have to find a few links to
the previous version of the character
and some bridges so it doesn't
completely detach from what he's already
masterfully achieved
mikkelson also appeared in an interview
alongside fellow fantastic beasts
co-star dan
fogler who plays the role of jacob
kowalski without going into too much
detail
mickelson and fogler stated that the
upcoming installment was
gonna be a great movie a small spoiler
was even revealed
when fogler mentioned that his character
jacob kowalski
is going to have a moment with
grindelwald i wonder what that scene is
going to entail
fogler himself also discussed his
feelings about depp's departure from the
series
describing them as a nitroglycerin
situation
he also revealed that he was sad
thinking about the previously mentioned
moment with depp
that he will now never be able to have
are you guys excited for the next
installment of the fantastic beasts
franchise
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
remember if you die you need not hand it
in
[Music]
you